it was a night which brutally exposed
the vulnerability of france's capital
and its citizens to the jihadist mindset
a night when terrorists armed with
explosive vests and assault weapons
carried out sustained and horrific
attacks people gunned down and blown up
at cafes and bars in the city
music lovers trapped here inside the
bataclan concert hall as terror is
centered
[Music]
oliver laplow was one of them there that
friday night with his wife in november
2015 he remembers hearing the first
gunshots
it was really loud and
i'm a musician so i'll play the guitar
and my first thought was the speaker
is it's just broken
the couple spent hours waiting for help
olivier will be forced to relive the
memory of what he witnessed as the
biggest criminal trial in french history
gets underway the policeman told us to
to close our eyes and
and as i was hitting something on the
floor or sleeping on something i just
had to go i just had to look
what i was doing and i saw
buddies and people shot and
heard people moaning in the in the pit
and
and still today i'll see them and i hear
them
90 people lost their lives here at the
bataclan on a night which stunned not
just this city but the entire nation and
the shock was compounded in the days
weeks and months that followed when it
was revealed that most of those accused
of carrying out the attacks either had
french or belgian nationality
at this trial france will be confronting
the issue of homegrown terrorism
central to the hearing will be french
citizen salah abdessalam said to be the
sole survivor of the isis attackers who
killed 130 people that night he ditched
his explosive vest and it would be five
months before he was arrested in the
mollembeck area of brussels his
childhood friend mohammed abrini who's
believed to have driven abdul-salam away
from paris was later caught on camera
during the attacks on brussels airport
and subways
another friend abdel hamid abud said to
be the mastermind of the cell was killed
in a raid on this apartment block in the
sandini area of paris five days after
the attacks
in all 20 people will go on trial in a
specially built high security courtroom
inside the former palace of justice most
are accused of helping facilitate the
attacks providing money weapons and
explosives and most were born and
brought up in europe actually home
ground terrorism has become the norm
these young people being born and raised
in france traveled to syria and then got
a real almost professional paramilitary
training and then we're able to come
back
to europe and then to perpetrate those
very deadly attacks
testimony from 1800 victims and families
will be heard during the nine-month
trial which will be conducted under
intense security salah abdul salam is
the only defendant facing murder charges
in previous court appearances he has
refused to speak or cooperate with
prosecutors few have high expectations
he'll behave any differently this time
michelle clifford sky news paris